-Thanks to newly developed
technology,
we here at "Late Night"
have the ability
to record the tiny voice that's
inside Donald Trump's head.
And you might
be surprised to know
that like
everyone's inner voice,
Donald Trump's is filled with
paralyzing fear and self-doubt.
So here it is, the tiny voice
in the back
of Donald Trump's head.
♪♪
-In my capacity as...
-Hey, Donald.
It's me, the tiny voice
in the back of your head.
Are you thinking
what I'm thinking?
Because I'm thinking
that Mike Pence
looks a lot more
like a president than you do.
I mean, look at him.
He's killing it right now,
speaking in complete sentences,
turning the page
each time he finishes a page,
not making insane gestures.
He looks like a real president.
And look at you.
You look like a guy
who won a contest
to stand next to a president.
I mean,
he's a complete freak and all,
but at least he can
fake being normal.
How does it feel
to be weirder than Mike Pence?
♪♪